au nom
des sérieux là
et qu'au bout
k c'est bon
doigts
[Musique]
oh
alors or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est peut-être le moment d'y aller là
non excellent anti
otan n'a pas payé l'addition c'est pas
grave sauf l on regarde regarde j'ai
toujours rêvé de faire ça
[Musique]
attention ma belle tu as failli se faire
écraser ah je vois tes accro à
l'adrénaline ça doit être dur de
toujours avancer comme une tortue tu
sais quoi aujourd'hui mademoiselle c'est
ton jour de chance
entre nous tu t'es déjà senti aussi
vivante
c'est super que ton sort vachement bien
tu s'est
rattrapé en plein vol
bon ce sera notre petit secret d'accord
tu m'as jamais vu je n'existe pas
[Musique]
vous vous attendiez à quoi un pieri sont
tous seuls qui mangent des limaces et
lutte pour sa survie
perdu on peut dire que je mène une vie
de château sur terre
j'ai une bibliothèque cliente
une salle de gym perso et un système de
sécurité dernier cri
[Musique]
non des vaisseaux volants sont peut être
impressionnant mister heckmann mais
regarde les choses en face tum attrapera
jamais la confiance et la piètre
doublure de l'intelligence
[Musique]
perso je ne sens pas trop
sonic toi tu as ta vitesse pour déplacer
mais nous avec m'a dit on est
complètement fichue bon vous écrabouillé
important soutien
pas de panique j'ai la solution qu'il
nous faut
[Musique]
je m'attendais pas ça bon d'accord je
m'attendais à l'inattendu donc c'est moi
qui gagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce matin
et
ouais
[Musique]
les hôpitaux
ok je sais ce que vous pensez pourquoi
ce hérisson incroyablement beau gosse se
fait courser par un faux avec une scène
qui date de la première guerre mondiale
franchement j'ai l'impression d'avoir
été obligé de courir toute ma vie vous
reprenez pas je vais trop vite ce primat
spécialité attendez on va remonter le
temps
[Musique]
voici lille d'où je viens
une île paradisiaque plages de sable fin
cascades vertigineuses montagnes russes
à volonté et j'ai jamais eu besoin de
prendre le bus pour aller à l'école
parce que je faisais le tour de l'île en
moins de deux secondes toute façon il
n'y avait pas d'école jeu c'est une île
de rêve je vous dis
je suis né avec des pouvoirs
extraordinaires mais on m'a dit de les
cacher et comme tous les enfants j'ai
fait le contraire évidemment
voici l'oncle ho c'est elle qui a pris
soin de moi en gros c'est obi wan kenobi
enfin si aubry avait un bug et manger
des souris sonic quelqu'un aurait pu te
voir non ça c'est impossible je cours
beaucoup trop vite et je voulais donner
ça
attention
mais qui dit super pouvoirs 10 super
méchant assoiffés de pouvoir et je les
avait conduits jusque chez nous
non
écoute moins attentivement son équipe tu
est doté d'un pouvoir comme je n'en ai
jamais vu il y aura toujours quelqu'un
qui voudra te le prendre ton seul moyen
de rester en sécurité cette vivre caché
ce monde se trouvent aux confins de
l'univers puis ce sera en sécurité mais
je veux pas y aller sans toi il le faut
ce sac d'amour sera tombe bien le plus
précieux
si un jour tu es découverte utilise un
nano ne s'arrête jamais de courir sauf
toi
adieu sadi
[Musique]